adam a large part of your character uh
here's this import looks like to me like
an impossible
costume to have to perform in
it looks like kylo has no
peripheral vision you have like a a slit
that you're peering through about that
big
how did that work out for you it was
terrible yeah but to this day i still
don't know who's in the movie because i
haven't seen anybody
[Music]
all right no it's i think when you watch
the original trilogy you always see
you know stormtroopers you moving in
uniform but what you don't see is when
one storm trooper just talking to a wall
because he thinks it's a person
our first day was together right that
was our very first day on set was
was a scene together i didn't see
anything and yeah and i remember you
didn't take off the helmet for a long
time
right and you're like it's me i'm in
here i'm in here the do you remember the
thing with the the voice
because uh there's been this you know he
rehearsed not to tell your story but
you've been
rehearsed this voice for a while like
working on it i just remember
the first thing being you know we did
the first take and then jj came up and
was like
yeah maybe maybe try something different
and you're like what
well yeah you know just try try
something else and then you started kind
of
pacing back and forth freaking out about
the voice right and i mean i was
thinking well
it doesn't matter what you sound like
because they can just do it over later
but
no one can see your face so that cares
no one cares
so then you did a southern accent